[Music]
hello and welcome back to chess openings
explained
as always my name is caleb denby and
today i
am going to be completing my series on
the najdorf with a quick look
at some of the sidelines you might come
across and then a look back
through the last glorious nine lectures
that we've done
i'm going to take a quick peek at all of
the main variations in the night or that
we've covered as well
so to start off with though i wanted to
wrap up by looking
at some of these sidelines that
went previously unmentioned throughout
the series so far
and to start with i wanted to start with
um
some strange queen moves that white can
play on move
six so let's get into it here uh of
course then out of arises from e4
c5 knight f3 d6 d4
takes takes knight f6 knight c3
and a6 and so of course we've taken a
look at pretty much all of the main
variations now
and what i mean by strange queen moves
well
white has a few options here such as
queen f3 queen d3
and queen e2 and i wanted to take a look
at all of these
talk a little bit about why these moves
are played and what the best way to
diffuse them
is so to start with i want to look at
what i think best
white's best option is out of these
three which is the move queen f3
so of course the idea of the nidorf is
you would like
you would like to play the move e5
gaining time on this knights
and controlling these dark squares in
the center of the board
and of course queen f3 is uh directly
trying to prevent this now of course if
you play the move e5
the move knight f5 is going to come the
point of
many of these sidelines is that white
has the move
knight f5 in case of
the move e5 by black now why is this so
bad for black well it's
sort of playable but the idea is
basically
eventually this knight is going to come
back to e3 and white's going to be able
to control the d5 square
very very fluidly and very easily
probably though he should start with
bishop g5
and then something like knight e3 is
coming quickly even queenside castles so
what should you do against this
well the downside to playing like this
so early on with white
is that black has not yet actually
played the move e5
and so this move looks a little bit less
intimidating if you simply play the move
e6 which is what i'm going to recommend
so queen f3 aims to control the light
squares uh
in the center of the board prepares the
move knight f5 in response
to e5 so black can just play the move e6
now if white continues with something
like bishop e3
he's just going to get sort of a worse
version of stuff we've looked at before
with the bishop on e3 why is this queen
on f3
i don't really understand black can just
develop normally something like knight
bd7
bishop b2 for example
and even the move h5 now to prevent this
move
g4 so i mean this is perfectly
playable for white it's just that it's
sort of a worse version of lines we
we've seen before
where this queen could be sitting on d1
or d2 with the pawn on f3
and then white's play would make a lot
more sense but h5 is sort of important
for black
in order to prevent this idea of g4 here
that being said if white doesn't waste
time with the move bishop e3 in bishop
e2
white is allowed to play g4 in this
position and this is
sort of the only line that has any kind
of venom
as far as these early queen moves go so
you do have to be on the lookout for
this one there are a variety of ways
that black can play
in response to this but i like doing
what
uh lenier dominguez did against an
opponent rodriguez villa
back in 2013 and
what dominguez did is just plays this
move knight c6
and i like this move because it pretty
much highlights why queen f3
has a few downsides uh by moving the
queen out to f3
white increases his control over these
light squares but
has abandoned this knight and white is
now forced basically to
capture on c6 black can recapture
g5 does come but the simple move knight
d7 is perfectly fine for black
and after some more development rook b8
black has a nice uh nice control over
the b
file and always has the opportunity to
play d5 at the right moment
in this game white actually queen's side
castled and black continued now with
queen a5
and it's pretty clear who is actually
the one attacking here
it's not really white despite playing an
early g4 g5
white's the one under a little bit of
pressure on the queen side
just for the sake of example the game
did continue with rook d4
c5 rook a4 so very clearly now
white a little bit worried about his
queen slide tried to
evict this queen queen b6 now b3
and uh black hit him with g6 here
with the idea of fianchettoing this
bishop and
sort of going for the checkmate and this
works very well for lenient dominguez in
this case
the game continued with uh queen g3
bishop g7
knight b1 queen c7 and this knight
arrived on the e5 square we see rook b4
an opening of the c file and in the game
there were some
sort of crazy tactics here but at the
end of the day
it heavily favored lenie dominguez when
after captures captures
knight a5 or queen a5 rather the
pressure on white's king
proved to be too much and white
sacrificed his queen
in order to stay in the game but it was
not enough and lenia dominguez did
go on to win so the key points i wanted
to highlight here
are after queen f3 don't play e5 just
play e6
and g4 is really the only line that is
critical
if white plays normally with bishop e3
we can develop with knight bd7
by the way don't play g4 here knight e5
would be a double attack
so bishop b2 first and then we can play
this nice move h5
just stopping g4 in its tracks and if g4
is played i like this line with knight
c6
captures captures g5 knight back to d7
bishop e3 played in this case and the
rook comes to b8
with pressure on the queen side of the
board
um okay so obviously i said there was
more than one queen move here
white also has the choice of queen d3 or
queen e2 but i don't think these are
quite as good as queen f3
let's look at queen d3 first here once
again
the idea is if f5 is played now knight
f5
can be played on the board and black's
typical response of d5
is once again not going to be ideal as
this can just be captured
uh if we try some funny tactic like e4
queen d4 is actually playable
with a check to follow so
uh e5 not going to be ideal here for
black
but once again the move e6 is perfectly
fine
um here white should
likely try and play a4 to slow down b5
if white doesn't do this play something
like bishop b2 b5 is actually going to
be a good move
just expanding on the queen side early
on so a4 is best i think
and once again we see knight c6 is a
good move
for black knight takes c6 for example
takes back
queen g3 d5 bishop d3 and
g6 was played in a game between gregory
opran
and boris gelfand back in 2017
and i do think once again this is going
to be perfectly fine for black
we see black once again going for the
fiance here
uh basically just stunting this queen on
g3
that white has spent two moves to uh to
place
this game continued uh in this manner
white plays a5 to gain some space
black castled we see a push in the
center by boris gelfand
and here black had absolutely no trouble
at all
in this game with two active bishops
uh and huge central control
for black so once again the remedy
to these strange queen moves queen f3
and queen d3
is just to play this idea of e6 and then
in both both
cases i'm recommending an early knight
c6 to
try and point out that white should not
be spending so much time with this queen
when it was serving a useful purpose on
d1
defending this knight on d4
if for example white declines this trait
of knights plays something like bishop
e2
well now we can take advantage of the
fact that this queen has once again
moved to a sub-optimal square this time
with the move knight b4
also taking advantage of the fact that
the pawn has moved out to a4
the queen can't really go this way we
have to keep a close eye on c2
otherwise we could fall to e5 so queen
d1
is the main move and now uh
with queen d3 queen d1 being how white
spent two tempi in the first nine moves
black should be doing
very very well here can you even
consider playing the move e5 once again
with knight f5 no longer being a good
response thanks to this idea of d5
coming back again
the last move i want to talk about as
far as early queen moves go
is this move queen e2 and once again
the idea for white is to take some early
control
of the light squares and against the
other two moves e6 was how i was
suggesting black should play and e6 here
isn't awful for black either
but it does turn out that queen e2
actually doesn't even
really achieve the goal it's set out to
and black can actually just play this
move
e5 why can black play e5 here well after
knight f5
there's an early g6 idea by black
knight e3 and all of a sudden it looks
like black
or white is achieving what he's set out
to achieve but after bishop e6 we still
have good control over the center and
this queen on e2
is nothing more than a hindrance for
for white interfering with development
and white will have to develop the
bishop out this way instead
when he would much rather place the
bishop on c4
to help directly control d5 just as an
example game there is one here between
alfonzo romero holmes with the white
pieces a 2500 player
and of course the incredible pentala
hari krishna with black and that game
went as follows g3 h5
is actually a really nice idea for black
to apply some pressure to this fiance
bishop
bishop g2 and the early h4 by hari
castles bishop h6 now activates the
bishop on this diagonal
rook d1 hg3 hg3 knight c6
highlighting the fact that white is uh
not defending
the d4 square very well and now we see
once again
the queen has to move for a second time
in the opening and this is really why
these queen
moves early on are just not going to be
that threatening the queen almost always
ends up
having to move again to uh to a better
square
so really no matter what happens with
the white pieces
uh he ends up spending a little bit too
much time moving this queen around in
the opening to make any tangible threats
uh in hari's game he did continue just
with the move
knight d4 and to just flip through
quickly we have 92
takes takes queen e7 b3 takes takes
and bishop h3 knight g4 and
uh in this game queen g5 was played we
saw a queen trade
f6 bishop d2 and hari was doing all
rights in
this endgame he did eventually actually
go on to win this game by the way
but i just wanted to highlight these
opening ideas with h5 and the early h4
being a very clever way to put some
pressure on white
so once again to recap queen f3 queen d3
uh they are very good moves for white if
black plays the move e5 because knight f
uh knight of five gives white a very
good position but black
isn't forced to do that can just play e6
followed by knight c6
putting some pressure on this knight and
then building a big center
queen e2 the worst of the three options
in my opinion
doesn't even do what it sets out to do
and allows black to play e5
with this idea of g6 and bishop e6 to
follow
when the bishop on f1 is difficult to
develop a difficult to develop
h5h4 another good idea for black there
so those are the early queen moves
obviously i didn't go too in depth on
all of these these are very much all
sidelines so i didn't want to spend too
too much time
and now i want to talk about what some
people may argue is not even a sideline
is just a very common move and that is
the theon kettle variations so let me
flip over here
of course the fee and kettle variation
is sort of self-explanatory we have the
opening moves of the nightdorf
knight f6 knight c3 a6 and as expected
the fianchetto variation
involves white uh fianchettoing and
there's basically two ways that these
lines can
go uh the the main way that
this fiance variation is played is just
not very threatening
at all of course uh the nydorf
for white to try and get some kind of
advantage the
white usually plays some crazy lines
like bishop g5 and early f4
uh and and early uh threats on the
center
uh or he could play positionally with
bishop e2
with g3 you basically get the bishop e2
style positions uh but instead white of
course puts this bishop on g2
and sort of spends two tempi to do it so
usually these positions
not super threatening to black this is
sort of just a way for players with the
white pieces
to avoid having uh it's a way for them
to avoid having to know a ton of theory
and they can sort of just get any kind
of playable position
with pressure on the d5 square that
being said
the old way they used to play this
variation actually can be a little bit
scary
if you are unprepared for it so i wanted
to highlight that as well
but first and foremost here of course
the typical night or move e5
is the way to go this knights can
actually step back
to the e2 square if the knight goes to a
square
like b3 or f3 we end up with positions
that are very similar to things we've
already looked at actually
involving bishop e2 so i don't want to
spend too much time there but knight d
e2 is really the main idea of the fiance
variation we don't mind blocking in the
bishop this way
because we are already going to put our
bishop on g2
here the normal night or development is
again the way to go
bishop e7 bishop g2 for example
castles and here
white should very much consider playing
the move a4
if white doesn't play a4 and just
castles while black
can get some very active play with the
move b5
and now in light of b4 coming soon
bishop b7 putting some pressure here
white should immediately jump to the d5
square
we can take this knight queen takes and
rook a7
is good enough here for black why is
this position fine
for black we've lost a tempo with the
queen on d5 hitting our rook on a8
well bishop e6 is going to come with
tempo black is going to eventually
organize his pieces on the c file and
this knight on b8 is going to develop
out to d7
eyeing c5 or b6 with more control of the
light squares
and black is just going to be doing uh
pretty well here
for example some normal development
would be bishop e3 hitting the rook
black is happy to play rook b7
and now generally white retreats this
queen before
any ideas of bishop e6 even happen
so queen d3 for example is my example
game bishop e6
b3 uh to stunt this bishop a little bit
knight d7 knight dc knight c3 net f6
a4 to try and break down some of these
pawns
queen d7 a b a b
rook a6 rook c8 and
black was doing uh pretty well here in a
game between
mickey adams and jan napomnishi also
back
from 2017 uh and yeah black really
doesn't have
any problems here rook fa1 was played in
the game b4
finally removes this knight knight a4
and this knight
is eyeing some dangerous looking squares
but it's not
really so threatening queen c7 attacks a
pawn
rook a2 knight d7 keeps this knight at
bay and trapped on the queen side of the
board and this game continued with queen
f1 rook b8
queen d1 h6 bishop f8
knight f6 bishop d7 bishop c6
black getting organized now against this
pawn on e4
and capturing it outright in fact bishop
a7 was a bit of a mistake by mickey
ricky ates
and black had a very good position here
up a central pawn
when the dust settles
and a piece sacrifice actually in this
game by jan but he gets it back
and wins another piece and goes on to
win this game
by the way that game from the moscow
grand prix back in 2017.
okay so that's why
white should consider playing a4 because
if castles b5
knight d5 takes takes rook a7 ends up in
a perfectly fine
position for black do you have to
remember all that theory
no you just have to remember the ideas
you get some pressure
on the c file you aim for b4 you get
your tempo back with bishop e6
and black is doing fine okay
let's take a look now at a4 really
quickly this is another perfectly fine
way of playing this
to try and slow down the idea of b5
but here there is a downside that comes
with playing a4 it's a downside we've
talked about before
in bishop e2 variations like i said that
these
variations share a lot of similarities
in that they're a bit quieter a bit more
positional
and the downside to a4 of course is that
it weakens the b4 square
and so black's idea should be the same
as when we see
a4 and those variations just shove this
knight onto b4
for example b3 bishop e6
and black has very good control over
this d5 square
white should try and remove this knight
from
from the b4 square with bishop a3
black can cement the knight here with a5
knight b5
is a main move and d5 for black
and actually the example game i chose
featured the move queen d2
and rook c8 first and still though
black's idea is going to be an early d5
here for example h3
now bishop h3 sorry upon h3 and d5 was
played in the game
with black breaking in the center and
freeing all of his pieces so
like i said very similar ideas to what
we've seen in bishop e2
when the move a4 appears on the board
you go knight c6 knight b4
and try to push for d5 okay that being
said
i mentioned that the old way of playing
these positions is
a bit more frightening and rather than
these king side castles or a4 positional
lines which you would most commonly see
nowadays
the move h3 used to be popular
with the idea that after black gain some
space on the queen side
you're gonna run into the move g4 and
all of a sudden
white is coming after you but uh this
isn't
actually all that frightening if black
were to play slowly with something like
bishop b7 well you might start to run
into ideas of knight g3 knight f5 but
thankfully with the black pieces we
don't have to play slowly and the move
b4
is a very immediate solution to many of
black's problems
knight d5 for example takes takes
and here you actually have the option to
play queen c7
but i think rook a7 is simple and also
perfectly fine
bishop e3 and in this case we can just
play the immediate bishop e6
the queen would retreat and we can put
the rook pretty much wherever we like
for example uh rook b7 was played in a
game
between teemo feyev 2690 and wang hao
back
in 2010 and black was doing perfectly
fine here the game continued with king
side castles
uh white sort of abandoning the king
side attack now because the situation on
the queen side is so open so volatile
and we saw black it developed f4 takes
takes
and knight e5 and here
like i said black's play on the queen
side has just come so quickly
that white's king side attack is sort of
over before it ever gets started
okay any questions on this fiance
variation uh because like i said
this is one of the more common
quote-unquote sidelines
that you're gonna run into uh the reason
i grouped it in
with these other sidelines is that it is
very similar to the bishop e2 variation
in many ways
and aside from this h3g4 stuff
it's not very threatening at all black
just plays normal
night or moves goes for this counter
play on the queen side
and gets developed as we've seen a
million times before
all right any questions on this before
we move on
yeah great wolf says this line feels
familiar that's because it is similar to
stuff we've seen
it's very similar all rights
let us move on then to our third
sideline
of the night i wanted to take a look
at the move uh that has appeared
in many different variations but has
never appeared
directly on move six of course i'm
talking about the move
a4 so with a4
white is stopping b5 before it ever gets
started
and now this is an idea of course that
white plays very often in many different
variations
where b5 is a good move for black but
playing it this early
uh isn't really ideal there's a reason
it's
a sideline and it's because when you
commit to a move like a4 so early on
you're sort of giving black a bit too
much information about what you're
playing for
there's absolutely no reason not to play
the normal night or move here
a4 isn't helping knight f5 in some way
so you are very justified in playing the
move e5
then i can retreat to f3 bishop b7
the normal night of development and now
bishop c4
is really the main idea of this a4
variation
but you have likely seen this type of
stuff before
where have we seen this stuff before
well let's take a quick look at
this move bishop e3 e5 knight f3
bishop b7 bishop c4 and this is why i
think
uh a4 is a bit of a sideline uh
if you're going to play like this why
are you putting your pawn on a4
instead of your bishop on e3 it's sort
of just
just a worse developing move right so
the ideas are going to be very similar
to this line that we've seen in the
bishop e3 variation
except of course white will have a4
played instead
e5 knight f3 bishop b7 bishop c4 and
once again
the idea is to contest this bishop by
playing bishop e6 the same as in the
bishop e3 line that we looked at
queen e2 queen c7 the bishop must
retreat to c3
and now once again because this pawn is
on a4
black is very happy to play knight c6
with potentially some ideas of knight b4
also some ideas of knight d4 or knight
a5 to pressure this bishop a bit
for example castles castles knight d5
bishop
d5 ed5 knight b4 uh was how
the game developed in a game between
elias mirren
and uh i believe sanan
zugarov uh something like that names are
hard to say
especially when they're russian and
black did actually go on to win this
game with a very pleasant position here
rook d1 was played in that case a5 helps
cement this knight on
the queen side c3 makes this knight move
away but now knight a6 is fine
bishop c2 was played work fe8s h3
g6 knight h2
and knight d7 knight g4 and a typical
night or idea
of f5 black just expanding on the king
side now
and this pawn on d5 really isn't going
to be ideal
for white you would much rather have a
piece here
as in many other lines and black is
going to be able to pressure a bit
pressure it a bit with something like
knight f6 in many cases
and can bring this knight over to c5
just a pleasant position
for black in fact in this game white
felt the black's position was so
pleasant that he should go a little bit
crazy and start sacrificing pieces
which is what happened with knight h6
knight of 5 and now after queen h5
knight f6 black ended up defending
pretty accurately
and then had a winning position with the
extra piece
pieces started coming off the board and
here black
is fully out of the water and just up a
full
knight pretty good h5 by the way played
bishop f3
takes rook f8 queen e3 knight takes f2
and elias mirren had seen enough with uh
sugrov
winning this game so
that is um a4 e5
knight f3 of course there are other
moves to be played here
there is the idea of knight b3 but
in this case after bishop e7 uh bishop
e2
castles castles believe it or not we
have seen this position before
in our bishop e2 lecture and here the
idea
is going to be the same we can simply
play the move b6
and develop out along normal
lines also uh i believe actually bishop
no not bishop b6 here no i'm sorry not
b6
it's the same uh stuff that we've seen
in bishop b2 but a4 has been played so
of course i was recommending
knight c6 taking advantage of the fact
that the b4 square
uh is weak this is the idea from the
bishop e2 lecture
uh and the idea holds true here because
it's the exact same position we just
transposed
so that's knight b3 after a4 there's
also knight d to e2
but hold on this is going to look pretty
familiar in just a second
castles bishop g2 knight c6
what's this we've seen this before
literally moments ago
when we were talking about
the move g3 right bishop a3
a5 should start looking pretty familiar
here it's the same variation
from the g3 sideline now
those were all the sidelines i really
wanted to devote a lot of time to
i will briefly mention a sideline here
which is going to be
a little bit combative there is the very
strange looking move
rook g1 to consider but
i didn't want to spend too much time
going over every single sideline
because there's just so much that's um
you basically can't cover it all in one
lecture and i think it's time to wrap up
the nydorf
basically against all the sidelines if
it's a move you're not familiar with
you should calculate if e5 knight f5 is
playable
if it's not then e5 should be your go-to
just like any other night or variation
and then typical night or development
is going to be enough for you to sort of
survive the day
but with rook g1 of course there are
some early threats of g4
but black again can just play this move
e5 knight p3 for example
and if you're really concerned about g4
then the move h5
is perfectly fine if you want to play
bishop b6 this is fine as well g4
and an early d5 is a good way to defuse
this idea
of rook g1 you know white's play on the
queen
king side looks a little bit lackluster
when you start to realize
that black is just breaking in the
center and white is wasting his time
sort of attacking nothing on the king's
side okay
any questions on any of the sidelines we
covered here today i know
there is you know more to talk about
with rook g1
but i don't want to get too bogged down
because i do want to spend the second
half of this lecture
going over taking a glance at
all of the stuff we've looked at before
and talking about that so any questions
before we start to review
the last nine lectures
what's the fallback if e5 doesn't work
uh well if e5 and the problem is
white is taking over the light squares
with the move knight f5
then the move is e6 right white spends
time controlling the light squares
but you haven't played e5 yet so you
play e6 controlling the light squares
and then generally i like an early
knight c6 in com
in combination with e6 although that's
not necessarily important
also just try and have a little bit of
awareness
because in many of these slide lines
you're going to be transposing into
stuff we've already seen or positions
very very similar to stuff we've already
seen
and that's why it's good to know ideas
rather than
the theory do you also need to know the
chevningen
pawn structures there are some
similarities there
but in general uh
in general i think it's it's more than
enough to just
know this knight of structure with e5 d6
the the situations when you play e6
really are going to be rare
it's going to be these weird sidelines
with queen f3 queen d3 that
aren't very testing or it's going to be
the sozen the fischer susan
with e6 right and i don't think this
actually has too much in common
with cheveningen stuff this is going to
be
the more theory-heavy stuff where black
just sort of tries to get developed
and then later on black is aiming to
play e5 anyways in most cases so
i don't think you need to know too much
about this idea of e6
but e7 is is fine
can we take a look at queen c7 and see
how things can go badly for white if he
grabs
the rook um sure so we'll take a quick
look
back at this idea which
was appearing in the g3 variation right
there's this idea of not defending your
rook
and going queen c7 instead and it's not
as though this is like a massive trap
for
for black or anything white can and
maybe should capture this rook
black's idea is just to trap the queen
on the queen side with knight c6
taking away this flight square bishop b3
uh bishop b7 and
wait let me make sure that yeah you
can't play bishop e7 here because of
queen a7 i was confusing myself a bit
but yeah knight c6 but bishop b3 bishop
b7 takes takes
and it's not really that black is
trying to check mate the white the white
king or anything it's just a situation
where the queen is going to be a little
bit more mobile
than the two rooks in this case there's
only this one half open file for the
rooks to use and they're going to end up
stunted by this bishop
so the queen is just a bit more
maneuverable and a bit better
in this position but you know you don't
even have to bother with this rook a7 is
perfectly fine for black as well
all right well then let's move on i want
to review everything we've talked about
so if my memory serves me correctly the
thing we
started everything off here was the
fischer sozen at least that was the
oldest study i could find on my profile
maybe we started with bishop b2 it
doesn't matter we're starting with the
sozen
now e4 c5 knight f3
d6 d4 takes takes knight f6
knight c3 a6 maybe i'll stop showing
these first five moves you've seen them
eight billion times now
um bishop c4 of course is the fischer
sozen
aiming on this light squared diagonal
but because black again
hasn't committed to e5 white's playing a
move that controls the light squares in
the center
black is happy to play the move e6 and
then the line i was recommending was a
little bit offbeat actually
we have this idea of bishop e7 and
then um there are sort of a few
different positions that you can sort of
get
white can try the typical sews in plan
of f4 f5 but that's actually what this
move order is sort of designed against
black can go for an early b5 here and if
f5
then e5 the knight comes back and bishop
b7
and black is actually doing very very
well in these positions
if he finds a really cool idea bishop g5
and who remembers the really cool idea
from
the uh the lecture on the fisher sozen
uh and by the way you know it might seem
outlandish
to get this kind of position with black
because
like if i can level with you black is is
doing very very well here
but the sozen you know on the surface
looks very very aggressive
but at the end of the day bishop on b3
is just kind of bad
right and so black is better in many
many lines who remembers the idea
knight takes c4 i don't think quite
works tactically
it's an interesting one but ah yeah we
can just
take this if we take here then knight
takes d6 is awkward so knight takes e4
isn't it
e5 is a rare move i think it's a pretty
common response to f5 in this case
i could be wrong on that all i know is
it's a good move
the idea believe it or not is actually
this move h5
the point is this guy is defending this
guy
and if he has to move out of the way
white is going to have
some pretty significant troubles and for
example the game might continue
takes takes white has to solve this
issue on e4
somehow if he does so with knight d5
look out for bishop takes d5 bishop
takes d5
and drook c8 and believe it or not if
you flip on an engine in this position
it's sort of
-1.5 black is just absolutely
killing it with pressure on the c file
ideas of
h4 to come and just the pressure on the
e4 pawn
is going to be very uncomfortable for
white to deal with
uh just for example the top engine line
believe it or not is bishop b3
h4 knight f1 and taking the free pawn
so goes to show you a little bit of what
white is up against in this variation
by the way queen d5 isn't so scary
knight g5 defense f7
okay so that's sort of what we're hoping
for in this variation
of the fischer susan however there are a
couple different lines that you do need
to be aware of
one is this idea of g4 and
here i believe i recommended the move
queen a5 and the point now
is black gets a lot of active play
against this e4 pawn early on
and the queen can help defend laterally
for example
the move f3 knight f
to d7 i actually don't remember if this
is what i recommended
but um stuff like this you go for queen
a5 and you go for
uh early play on the queen side with
stuff like knight c6
uh once again the idea is more important
than the actual theory in many many
cases
i actually don't remember this move
knight fd7 probably i recommended this
move knight c6 right away
but there's these g this g4 idea i just
wanted to briefly mention
there's also the idea of castles b5
f4 sorry queen f3
is a bit more common uh bishop
no queen c7 now we can meet e5 with
bishop b7
queen g3 castles bishop h6
and 98 and once again we're just gonna
go bishop b7
we're gonna have pressure on the e4 pawn
and black is doing perfectly fine here
because this bishop is lame stupid
stupid bishop on b3 looking at an e6
pawn
okay that's this fisher sozen at a
glance
obviously if you want to know all the
details on all these lines
go watch the fisher sews in lecture this
is just a review
up next i wanted to go over at a glance
the complicated line of bishop g5
once again i'm recommending e6 f4 h6
with the delayed poison pawn championed
by maxime vashilograv
and now queen b6 and while
this stuff has the reputation reputation
of being very very
theory heavy very very complicated
there's really only two main ideas you
need to be aware of there's the idea of
a3
and the idea of queen d2 a3 of course
goes down a variation where black cannot
capture on b2
but weiss white has wasted some time
with a3 and also created a hook
for black to sort of attack a little bit
later on and the game here might
continue bishop e7 natural development
bishop f2 queen c7 stepping off the
diagonal
queen f3 knight bd7 developing castles
b5
developing bishop b7 and here of course
the two ideas
bishop g2 and h4 bishop g2 a bit more
common
now black can go g5 to break down the f
pawn in the center
and some of you may remember this game
between maxine vashir lagrav
and sergey karjakin which mvl managed to
win quite convincingly by outmaneuvering
his opponent
activating his pieces and
winning some material at the end of the
day
from i believe the london chess classic
and mvl goes on to win the sun game
easily with d5 when karjakin resigns
so that's the idea with a3
you go into this variation with white
castling queen side
black staying in the center for a bit
and black is doing perfectly fine with
pressure on e4
the idea of queen d2 is to accept the
poison pawn
and then here uh this e5 move
is really the only way to apply the most
pressure here if you do anything else
black can sort of get his pieces back
into the game there are some important
lines to know though
so if you want to see those go back to
the bishop g5 lecture but at a glance
e5 and you go in for this theoretical
variation
and this is something you might just
have to memorize unfortunately
and the idea is black has won a few
pawns
but after bishop d6 black is going to
return the exchange with f5
and from here knight bd7 and white has a
variety of moves
but black's idea is going to be pretty
much the same against all of them
with g4 you can first capture this pawn
and then trade queens at all costs
basically no matter what happens
you trade queens castles queen c5 trade
queens
um bishop f3 um queen a1 check
d1 queen e5 trade queens just
just trade the queens that's all you got
to do to survive this variation is trade
the queens
and that's the bishop g5 move basically
the delayed poison pawn
up next let's take a look at the english
attack at a glance
bishop e3 denotes the english attack we
go e5
knight b3 we talked about the knight f3
line a little bit earlier in the lecture
by comparing it to the knight f3 after
the move a4
and here we go bishop e7 bishop f3
bishop b6
the idea is we're threatening d5 if
white gets
a little bit too careless so queen d2
and now the idea is
h5 and the point here is we have so
thoroughly
uh prevented white's king side attack
that he sort of has to give up on it and
go for some knight d5 ideas instead for
example queen side castles
knight t7 king b1 b5 and already knight
d5 should be played
we can take and thanks to our placement
of our knights we can apply pressure
here
and white is forced to go in now for
some kind of end game with knight a5
and usually knight c6 when we have
equality here alternatively
if white wants to be uh super fancy
after h5
he can give up on this queen side
castling all these ideas all together
and just play knight d5
immediately but now we can actually
capture with the knight preserve our
bishop
and here this a5 move is rather
important preventing
white from placing his own knight onto
the a5 square
and getting a positional uh clamp on us
and then here
black is doing perfectly fine um
and yeah black is is doing perfectly
fine it's basically the moral of the
story here of the entire naidorf
all rights let's take a look at the
bishop e2 variations at a glance
the bishop e2 lines of course the more
positional stuff that we looked at
uh first or maybe second i can't
remember
the idea for white is that he's not
going after some crazy attack
he's just going to castle king's side
and play for d5 control
as in a lot of the bishop g or a lot of
the g3 bishop g2 stuff we looked at so
e5 still the move bishop b7
normal development here bishop b6 to
follow knight bd7
and a4 a5 is probably white's best try
for an advantage to clamp down on these
pawns but now
a good idea for black to break free is
queen c7
rook d8 and breaking out with knight c5
and white very much should be capturing
this piece
and then after for example takes takes
king h1
queen c6 black is doing perfectly fine
here
this is taken from a game between vasily
ivanchuk and look vanveli
and i think they repeated very very
shortly in the game
basically white black is going to play
the move c4
take a little bit of extra space and
white is sort of just without a plan
at that point um if you want to see the
rest of this game by the way
f3 c4 bishop f1 and here
repetitions arrived and that was enough
for a draw
in the european cup in 2008.
[Music]
other ideas i wanted to mention for
white there is sort of one tricky line
here
we looked at the move bishop e3 when
black can play bishop e6
notably we're not scared of f4 after
bishop b3 because white has taken some
time
white can also try the move a4 to stop
b5
but now remember knight c6 we talked
about it briefly earlier in the lecture
as well
white has weakened the b4 square and
black is doing fine
and the move king h1 is sort of
highlighting the fact
that black's response to bishop e3 was
bishop e6 because white wasted time
and white's response to a4 was knight c6
because white weakened a square
so now with king h1 white isn't wasting
time with the bishop
and white isn't weakening the b4 square
so what can we do
do we just relent and play one of these
moves anyways
no we play the move b6 the point now
being
we haven't sort of revealed our plans
either and after
the move f3 we go bishop b7 bishop e3
um sorry not bishop b3 if bishop e3 we
can go
b5 with an early b4 in response to a4
so white should try a4 himself and then
once again knight c6
knight b4 and we see the ideas we've
seen a million times before
with black breaking in the center with
d5
okay that's bishop b2 at a glance and
then one more thing i wanted to take a
look at at a glance
is the h3 variation that we went over
last week of course
this is six h3 and the idea here
is going to be an early e5 once again
knight
d to e2 is the point of h3
and this is sort of this h3g4 stuff that
we we've seen in the g3 line
uh earlier this lecture but the
difference now
is with white only getting g4 in one
move instead of two
i think it is in black's best interest
to play h5 here and just stop
g4 uh altogether and now
g3 it should be the backup plan for
whites
bishop b6 and now b5 normal nyodorf
stuff
you put all the pieces on the squares
you play b5 and in this case
knight takes d5 e takes d5 bishop f5 and
if you recall we went over a game in the
previous lecture between sergey karjakin
with the white pieces when he tried this
queenie one move and mixing the sherlock
with the black pieces
and black ended up winning this game
pretty convincingly
with some clever ideas of h4 takes
and as always in the nightdorf you just
always have squares
for your pieces one more idea in the h3
variation
after h5 black is weakening the g5
square so white could try to take
advantage of it with the move
bishop g5 here i like bishop e7 instead
of bishop e6
with the point being after takes takes
knight d5 we can get the bishop out to
an active g5 square
rather than leaving it sit on f8 just
for example adc3 bishop b6 bishop c4
knight c6 castles and rook c8 and black
is doing well here
with once again all of his pieces having
active squares to
sit on and okay
for the last 10 minutes i wanted to open
up
to any and all questions anybody has
about the entirety of the nydorf
this is it this is the finale i have
recapped the
the last nine lectures in 20 minutes
i've gone over a few sidelines
did i miss your favorite sideline now's
your chance to tell me people in the
live youtube audience
what if a4 in the english ending
uh okay we'll take a look
so i assume we're talking about um
this night do and what if a4 here
um probably just king e7 right we are
evicting this rook rook probably has to
go back here
and we can even capture this pawn we're
not so worried about this right rook b8
and yeah i mean this this is just a
quality uh
all around in fact maybe black is the
one playing
for more ideas of a3 to come for sure
then rook d2 okay i mean we're sort of
just playing a chess game if you don't
like b takes a4
play rook b8 as well first black is
doing fine here
i mean uh this is more of an end game
discussion than an opening discussion
just trust me black can do like 80
different things
white can do like 80 different things
it's not going to change the evaluation
too drastically
should be equality
all right is that the only question
anybody has about the nightdorf
uh somebody's mentioning that i uh made
a mistake apparently
uh what were we talking about with this
knight takes e4 stuff oh yeah we're
talking about the fischer susan
i'm talking about the fischer susan so
let's take a look at this again see if i
actually
messed up here because if i did it would
be important to correct not knight takes
e4
we talked about that h5 here
and in this line i mentioned this and
you guys are saying there's bishop takes
f7 and queen d5
is it true is it true bishop takes f7
king takes f7 uh
i i mean it's true but like is it so bad
is it so so bad
i think black is is winning i think
black is just winning this position to
be honest
it's tough tough tough for white just
because you see a tactic doesn't mean
the tactic wins the game
how to know when to play h5 in general
so that's a good question
we did touch on that topic a little bit
during the english attack
so let's go back to the english attack
variation in particular
and talk about why h5 is played here and
why it's not played in other cases
so here when
can you play h5 you can play h5
when white has wasted time with the move
bishop e3
and that's 90 of the time when h5 is
going to arrive
when this bishop on c1 has already moved
once
why should you avoid playing h5 when the
bishop on c1 has not moved
well that's because then it's very often
a good idea
if i can remember a line when this would
even be possible
it's usually a good idea for white to
put the bishop on g5 taking advantage of
the fact that the pawn is on
h5 so when the bishop has already moved
once then bishop g5 is much much less
powerful
because white is wasting a full tempo to
uh to get it
now when do you want to play h5 well you
might want to play
h5 whenever white is thinking of playing
the move
uh thinking of playing the move g4 so
even today
we saw in one of these queen moves
variation uh bishop or queen f3
e6 and bishop e2 for example
knight bd7 no sorry bishop b3 for
example knight bd7 bishop b2
and here once again we played h5 because
white was thinking of playing g4
and here notice as well the bishop has
already wasted time
with the bishop coming to e3 the
only exclusion to this is this h3 line
when we play h5 with this bishop on c1
to my knowledge in all of the lines i'm
recommending this is the only time you
see this
pawn land on h5 before white has wasted
time
with the bishop and here we do it
because
h3 is sort of made
out to be a useless move by h5
so rather than white wasting a tempo
here this is sort of my justification
for it
h3 is almost as useless as just even
moving the bishop twice so that's why i
think h5 is perfectly playable here
other than that just specifics work out
there's also this knight on e2 by the
way
preventing this bishop from accessing
the d5 square immediately
and because of these slight awkward
moves
here h5 is playable as well but this is
the exception to the rule
generally h5 is bad when the bishop can
land on g5 in one turn but that's an
excellent question
okay how to punish a premature e5 in the
bishop g5 and bishop c4 lines
uh i can't um
i haven't prepped for the najdorf uh
with white i don't play one e4
i only know that playing e5 early in
those lines is generally
bad i don't need to know why i just do
it because e6
just makes sense the bishop's on c4 you
play e6 the pawns on f4
uh in the bishop g5 variation well
actually you know bishop g5
you don't play e5 because then this pin
is awkward and d5 is weak
bishop c4 you don't play e5 because d5
is weak
it just makes sense it generally has to
do with d5 being
being weak okay jonathan has a question
as well what do you do against 6 bishop
e2
let's go to our bishop b2 at a glance
here
bishop b2 e5 knight b3 bishop e7
bishop e3
i don't think this has too much
independent value with castles here you
can just play the move bishop e6
note once this bishop moves from c1
we're not worried about f4
because the bishop would waste time by
coming to f4 here
and then i think white's best move is
castles if you play the early knight d5
this actually isn't too threatening
we're not worried about stuff like 97
bishop g5
because once again the bishop has wasted
time
and i think i did go over this line in
depth in the bishop e2 lecture
but basically yeah black king castle
here white king castle
oops not rook g1 but castles and we can
take this guy off the board
and then i think i mentioned
two variations here i mentioned going
like rook c8 queen c7
and i also mentioned the active idea of
98 followed by
by f5 did i cover 99 d5
i think yeah i if i'm remembering
correctly i have a whole chapter in my
study about 9.95 um
i couldn't recite the entirety of it too
but the basics of it was to start with
knight d7 castles
then we play this bishop takes knight
and there's this idea of 98 f5
uh in in some move order sometimes i
included
rook c8 i i'm not sure if i include rook
c8 but 98 f5
is the idea for black there
are there any cases where pouncing on b4
after a4
is not good well chess is always a game
of specifics
um in general uh if you're not sure
i would recommend doing it doing a bit
of calculating
if you're seeing some reason why knight
b4 wouldn't work
if your knight is actually not going to
reach b4 uh in some position where a4 is
on the board
then don't do it right chess is a game
of specifics and you should rely
on your feelings at the board your
calculations as well as your prep
basically i like knight c6 heading for
b4
after a4 in almost every case because
it's difficult for white to prevent it
it just
really is difficult uh and the important
things to remember are following it with
a5 when your knight is getting kicked
away and you can come back to a6
quite comfortably obviously sometimes
your knights are already on d7 when a4
is played in many of the bishop e2
variations that we've seen
and then you just adjust your play right
and go a5 b6 put the knight on c5
just all the ideas the e pawn is hanging
uh
yeah i don't think the e pawn can be
captured here i don't remember why
um there's some tactic in this position
i'm quite sure here i'll flip on the
engine yeah bishop b6
tough tough stuff
[Music]
how to evaluate when to play e6 versus
e5 we've talked about that a little bit
tonight already
basically e5 is the night or move and
that's what i recommend
e6 is basically always playable you just
get the cheveningen structures
but e5 is the nidorf idea when shouldn't
you play it
well on these sidelines you shouldn't
play e5
if there's some reason why knight f5 is
good basically if white can play knight
five after e5
you've done something wrong and you
should play e6 so queen f3 prepares
knight f5 queen d3 prepares knight f5
i think even the move a3 indirectly
prepares an f5
and in those cases it makes sense to
play the move e6 other than that
the move e5 should be perfectly fine as
that is the idea of the najdorf
okay i think then i'm going to go ahead
and call it here
i know this wasn't our typical night or
lecture we went over a few new things
and then i gave you a quick glance back
at everything we've covered
so far and then we had this little q a
session so
hopefully you guys enjoyed this lecture
here tonight
that is going to conclude my coverage of
the
entirety of the night or of course the
night or for such a massive opening
there's always going to be more stuff
and more detail that we can cover but
hopefully if you've made it through all
10 of these lectures
you should have a very good working
understanding of the opening
and you should feel confident pulling it
out in order to uh to play the opening
i should say the best way and really the
only way
to learn openings is to try them out
don't be afraid of
losing a few quick games because you
don't remember something
the best way to learn opening is is to
play it you have to play it you have to
put it into practice you have to see
what people are doing what you're
struggling with
and then hopefully these videos will
help serve as a little bit of a
reference guide
to those as well well that's it
thank you guys so much for sticking it
out with me throughout the entirety of
the night or
be sure to tune back in next week for
more chess openings explained
when i do something different entirety
uh if you're watching live head over to
the twitch channel where i will be going
live with tactics time
if you're watching the youtube version
thank you once again my name is caleb
denby and i will see you
next time
you